qu'est-il advenu du sous-marin Titan
s'est-il perdu dans les profondeurs de
l'Atlantique aux côtés de l'épave du
Titanic qu'il était parti explorer à son
bord 5 passagers un pilote et 4
touristes richissimes dont le
spécialiste français du Titanic pôle
Henri narjolais le contact a été perdu
seulement deux heures après la plongée
et la zone de recherche est très
difficile à atteindre la demande express
se d'Emmanuel Macron et bien un navire
français de l'Ifremer qui est vous le
savez placé sous l'autorité du ministère
de la mer et du ministère de
l'Enseignement de la recherche
supérieure et bien a été dérouté
l'Atalante équipée d'un robot sous-marin
télécommandé capable d'inspecter les
grands fonds marins il devrait renforcer
les équipes de secours américaines
canadienne déjà sur place et donc vous
le voyez c'est une course contre la
montre qui est engagée depuis hier soir
et donc la France a répondu présent à
l'appel bien évidemment des autorités
américaines travailler plus longtemps
pour sauver notre système de retraite
c'est la promesse du gouvernement pour
faire passer la réforme une promesse
impossible à tenir dans les prochaines
années selon le Conseil d'orientation
des retraites dans son rapport annuel le
corps affirme que l'équilibre financier
ne sera pas atteint comme promis d'ici
2030 c'est une plaisanterie ou c'est
parce que
écoutez je pense qu'il faut dire aux
Français qui va falloir en fait
travailler jusqu'à 65 66 ans dites-le
technicien qui sont là derrière la vitre
ici à France Info et des salaires qui
sont plus faibles dépensons de retraite
qui sont indexées sur l'inflation
résultant d'un déficit du régime des
retraites qui sans doute plus élevées
le corps je pense avec beaucoup de
prudence que c'est vous voyez bien que
ces évaluations changent tous les six
mois dans trois des quatre scénarios
étudiés par le corps les contes ne
repasseraient dans le verre qu'après
2045 dans le meilleur des cas Conseil
d'orientation des retraites se basent
toujours sur des projections ou les
salaires n'augmentent pas en fonction de
l'inflation ou il n'y a pas un taux
d'emploi de le plein emploi c'est à dire
zéro chômeur dans notre pays avec un
taux de chômage qui restait levé ce
qu'on s'appelle enfin trouver des
nouvelles recettes par exemple en
faisant cotiser le capital en augmentant
les salaires en créant de l'emploi une
dame de 73 ans et sa petite fille de 7
ans sont sur le pas de la porte sur
l'autre trottoir un homme les épiques
lorsqu'elle rentre chez elle il se
précipite bloque la porte les saisies et
les jettes à terre ça je peux le dire
les images que nous avons vu sont
absolument insupportables quelques
secondes après il récupère au sol le
collier qu'il a arraché à la grand-mère
puis prend la fuite effrayer selon les
policiers par les aboiements du chien la
police et la justice sont à l'heure
actuelle pleinement mobilisés pour
apporter à cette agression la réponse
pénale quelle qu'elle mérite moi aussi
ça m'est arrivé de me faire agresser
nous arrive à tout le monde mais je
pense que la ville de Bordeaux on est
conscient
la ville de Bordeaux est conscient de ce
qui se passe au niveau de la sécurité on
est conscient et on y travaille pas
délinquance l'aggravation de la
délinquance porte en elle une raison qui
est dirimante qui est l'explosion de
l'immigration anarchique les Français il
est né en France deux parents français
et cela retire évidemment rien à l'acte
ignoble qu'il a commis je voulais
évidemment m'associer évidemment au
drame pour les victimes qui nous a tous
beaucoup touchés Marine Le Pen a-t-elle
parlé trop vite ce matin là c'est
évident lorsqu'elle a évoqué cela cet
homme est né en France en 1993 oui cet
homme est né en France pour autant je ne
pense pas que les origines de cet homme
soient bordelaises
français n'est à Bordeaux il est sous
tutelle et souffre de troubles
psychiatriques il a déjà été condamné à
15 reprises notamment pour des affaires
de stupéfiants il est noir
est-ce qu'on peut élever le niveau mais
excusez-moi c'est vous qui venez de dire
ça est-ce qu'on peut élever ce qui vous
permet de dire que ces origines ne sont
pas niveau sa couleur de peau vrai ne
vous en déplaise et je sais que ça vous
chagrine parce que c'est votre fond de
commerce
immigration psychotique et schizophrène
l'homme ne prenait plus son traitement
après examen il a été conduit cet
après-midi dans un hôpital psychiatrique
de Bordeaux Cussac c'est la bière corona
qui a eu le président lors de la finale
du Top 14
le médecin que vous dites dit bravo et
pour Matignon oui ma réponse elle est
très simple quand on est heureux
mais quand on est heureux un poste il
faut pas envisager un autre mais oui
c'est une philosophie de vie qui est
saine que le médecin qui n'a jamais fait
ça une fois dans sa vie me jette la
première bière Laurence Ferrari